sexual orientation describes who you are
attracted to
may fall in love with and may have a
sexual relationship with
they said well why don't you look it up
in the urban dictionary and i did and i
was quite
shocked at what i found i'm not going to
even say what it means but if you want
to know what it means
after some discussion in counseling you
may be referred to
an endocrinologist endocrinologists
specialize in hormones
and they are the most likely to
prescribe puberty blockers for someone
who wants them
puberty blockers are medications that
will stop your body from changing
it's coming in so many different
directions this um disney movie onward
and on the dean's show we have brenda
lipsack how are you
i'm doing well thank you eddie it's nice
to have you back on the program
we had you on some time ago and for
those people that
didn't get a chance to watch that
episode really strongly encourage them
to go back and watch that
episode that we did you're a school
teacher of 30 years can you fill us in a
little bit about
what you do and who you are for those
who didn't get acquainted with the first
time that we met
yes thank you for having me on um and
i'm
i want to be culturally sensitive i'm
not muslim however
i am a person of faith a god-fearing
person who loves children
and loves people and so i wanted to be
culturally sensitive
and wear a scarf um so i'm not offensive
to anybody
in the audience um but thank you again
for having us on
i've been a school board member in
orange county um for four years
so i've been on the inside i've been a
teachers union member for over 25 years
and i've been a school teacher in the
state of nevada and mostly in the state
of california
i've taught pretty much all the grades
i've taught
high school and middle school english
history but now i'm a pe teacher for
kids
disabled kids in orange county
now you've been kind of giving us the
inside scoop of what's going on
some things that are kind of just under
the table or
overtly kind of pushed into the
curriculum and many parents they're just
not
aware of this you've kind of been
bringing us up to speed
tell us now last time when we talked we
talked about
there was like a deliberate attack on on
muslim children
can you bring us up to speed on what we
were talking about then and we'll go on
with uh the
this week's uh up-to-date information
that you're bringing us
absolutely um yes just
as i mentioned before um and i do hope
people will watch the last video because
i'm i'm gonna overlap a little bit but
it'll help if they watch it
um basically you know the lgbtq
that's really coming into a lot of the
subjects it's
not just coming in through sex education
now it's coming in through
ethnic studies it's coming in through
social emotional learning
under identities under empathy
inclusion diversity anti-bullying
creating welcoming schools it's coming
under all those many umbrellas and we're
seeing it more and more
um pushed in through the teachers union
um
through legislature through laws and
bills and policies
for school districts so there's a
particular
um agency called advocates for youth
they actually
wrote the national sex ed standards that
a lot of school districts
and state departments are using
and in looking over uh their 20 20
revised uh national sex
ed standards and also uh their
ethnic studies and things i'm seeing yes
a lot more emphasis
towards muslim youth and i wanted to
show you
some of those things as examples just so
muslim parents can be aware they can
talk to their kids about it
and i'm i'm hoping not to overwhelm
parents because i know this can be
overwhelming
but i'm hoping to also empower and i
have a website now when before i was on
your show i didn't have a website
i only had facebook and facebook is now
being highly censored
so i'm trying to go more through my
website now to provide
um materials you know that people can
look at and documents
from the last program we did what kind
of response did you get from the
community
oh you know i read a lot of those um
comments under the video and i did get a
lot of emails and a lot of facebook
friend requests and absolutely
you know encouraging for one to me
because
it's not easy to speak out about these
things i'm grateful to still have a job
but i also received
some insight um and i have been in
contact with some people from other
countries
um and learning from them so i think the
more that we can
share information and help one another
for the sake of our children and to be
honest for the sake of humanity
because as i share some things with you
it's very alarming
um on some of the things that are going
on um
but yeah there was one person actually
that shared with me
when he saw some of the samples that we
shared on our last show with
the videos and the books he said you
know besides targeting muslims it looks
like they're targeting people of color
um african americans because and you
know it was like a light bulb went on
for me
and i looked and i'm like yeah you're
right and so i
actually reached out to some um
african-american ministers and lawyers
in los angeles
and i'm working with them now um and
they're starting to be a voice and
speaking out about this as well
very interesting so let's go through you
have a
presentation is this and you have some
pictures here
it starts off with i'm muslim and i
might not be straight
and then this is a resource uh for this
uh
alphabet movement and then the uh muslim
youth what is this about alphabet
movement you're funny
okay so this is actually one of the
resource
toolkits from advocates for youth
advocates for youth
puts out an online highly recommended
through at least the california
department of education i know it's not
just california though i know
michigan there's different states that
are using advocates for youth
um the three r's and san diego unified i
know is definitely using this curriculum
but they reach out to kids um
on many virtual platforms to try to
create a safe inclusive environment and
they have these
quote unquote trusted adults that they
can talk to
um and i just want parents to be aware
of this
because a lot of these things are going
on online
and so parents don't know who their kids
are talking to
they have hashtag amaze ask amaze
um they can reach out to people these
anonymous people
on um instagram text messaging
um and they call them trusted adults
that are that are vetted through
advocates for youth
but this is the kind of things that
they're telling kids and it's not
in a way that's going to build a
relationship with their parents in fact
it will
i believe cause uh dissension
between parents and kids
now how would you like for us to go
through should i go through each one of
these
slides that you have that would be great
we can start from the first one
so this one um i'm muslim and i might
not be straight
a resource for lgbtq plus muslim youth
i want you to see carefully that plus
because that plus is
open-ended um and they're changing
definitions
so now the queue means queer or
questioning
and queer now according to the national
sex
ed standards of 2020 put out by
advocates for youth
and um it means um
queer is an umbrella term anytime they
use the word umbrella
that means open-ended ever-expanding
ever-evolving ever-changing
so that could mean anything
and i've tried to call them out on that
um
by saying okay that's even saying that
you're not explicitly stating that
pedophilia is an exception
so it's it's quite interesting um
so that's one of their you could go to
the next one um
now muslim and the reason
they're using this as their advocacy
program is and means that
it's a word called intersectionality
meaning that you're muslim
and what other identities are you
whether it be
queer um gay it could be anything
any type of sexual orientation polymory
um there's many asexual
um and they're saying you don't have to
give up your faith identity in order to
be
a different gender that's not conforming
or a different sexual orientation that's
non-conforming
here's another example um
from the toolkit it says as a 20 year
old queer non-binary
you're going to have to help me with
some of these um words
hijabi yeah hijabi
uh muslims do you want to read that yeah
so it says as a 20 year old queer
non-binary hijabi muslim hijabi muslim
simply one who
observes like the that modest dress code
uh
the muslim yeah this is uh for for
anyone who's tuning in and just
maybe who's a christian i mean uh this
is like kind of imitating uh mary the
mother of jesus
have you ever seen her on google like
not those pictures that they have
representing of her it's not actually
her but you always see her in hijab so
that's uh what it is hijab uh my parents
often say
there aren't any lgbtq the letters uh
people in our community my mosque often
says that you cannot be
lbg and a muslim the government often
says that me and my family are not
welcome in this country in the first
place what i've come to understand is
that muslims have existed
since the beginning of islam that queer
muslims have existed since the beginning
of islam
we existed and allah made us just this
way
so this is uh in your slide here yes
so i think that picture um
i can't read it it's my my queer
it's my yeah image
description library muslim sits in a
peaceful position as words my
greatness is my own and my and i may
share it whoever i desire
circulated around the head so i mean the
way i see this is because
before i was a teacher i was
so this are this is this where do kids
see this is this is this something that
now
this is uh uh in the in a curriculum or
this is being taught in the school or
the these kind of quotes are being
shared how
how does this fit into uh the education
system yeah that's a good question
okay so what they do is they have
the baseline curriculum and i'll show
you some of those videos from the
baseline curriculum today
um starting even in elementary school
but
then they have resources that and they
tell kids if you have more questions
here's the resources here's the links
now what kids don't have more questions
about sexuality especially teenagers
so they will have these links um
specifically for muslims um
and that if you have more questions for
muslims and you can reach out to a
trusted adult
um to ask your questions and all of
these trusted adults
have been trained to say that
you know sexual identities and gender is
unlimited
and whatever you know your gender is
something that you can discover
explore it is your unique identity
that no one can take from you and so
they encourage them
to um explore that identity and
if they say if the child says my parents
aren't affirming of this they don't
agree with this
um then they kind of let them know well
then don't tell their parents because we
want to keep you safe
and they make it out like your parents
if they don't affirm these
ideologies are harmful this one i i
don't even feel comfortable putting it
really on
on the screen it's there just real quick
but you have
i mean this is like really uh from an
islamic perspective this is very
inappropriate even if it's
like a husband and wife i mean this is
something that you do you know
uh behind the scenes you know it's it's
something special
it's not so you have so you have this
kind of making out here like almost
french kissing or something whatever
right right
all right yeah what's going on with that
and what's going on why are they doing
that
they're showing this to the young young
young ones the young minds
okay well this is um that picture that
you saw
they have an instagram for and it's not
even it's not even like something just
like a cute little like
peck or something this is like really
like almost like pornography
like pornographic just like we're in
like you're into it just put it out
there
you know it's very distasteful it's on
the eve
that's on the muslim and instagram so
uh one of the kids probably put that
up as their yeah just from our
perspective even if you had a boy and a
girl
you know doing this kind of making out i
mean this is something that's just
inappropriate all around you know it's
just
i'm i'm just kidding so that's really
mild compared to a lot of other things
that are in the sex
education pretty much yeah wow
okay so this is um something that one of
the
kids posted on the um support instagram
that advocates for youth puts out and
you know it's advocates for youth
because they have the little emblem in
the corner
and the muslim and the hashtag so it
says in solidarity with black and brown
young queer and trans muslim people who
have to fight against multiple systems
of oppression
so as they're teaching kids now through
ethnic studies critical race theory
um some of you might not be familiar
with that but i'm gonna
try to put more information on that in
my website
but basically it talks about um people
groups that are marginalized and people
groups that have privilege
so those that are the oppressors and
those that are
the oppressed and the marginalized
people would be
minorities people of color um the
privileged or the
the superior ones of power
would be white men
christians and heterosexuals so
anybody and cisgender cisgender means
um identifying as biologically male
or female okay so if you're not
if you're not biologically male or
female you're identifying as something
else then you're considered oppressed
such as transgender or genderqueer
or non-binary okay
this group that you mentioned this is a
muslim
organization muslim and is what they're
doing through advocates for youth
as it says in their name is they are
teaching kids to be
political activists um for their cause
so their cause might be to
create laws and policies
they're teaching them how to create laws
and policies to
promote um
things that will help lgbtq
or it could you know that kind of thing
yeah you tell me i'll start going
through these and you tell me where you
want me specifically to stop
and then you can go yeah so i just so
okay
you're seeing like the last one that you
just saw um how do i know that i'm queer
that's and that is produced through
advocates for youth
so that's the that's the one that's
endorsed
um by the california department of
education it's in our health framework
um it's it's endorsed six times
in our health framework to teachers and
to students
okay so that's part of their um
that's part of the curriculum that they
endorse okay this here
isn't in the curriculum what this is is
a picture
from the student instagram um that's put
out
by advocates for youth it's kind of a
platform that they've created
so that kids can connect with one
another
and feel supported by one another
but education department
now if you're like most people now doing
schooling online
and you know you have the k curriculum
is it you know which one i'm talking
about curriculum
yeah it is called and this is where most
uh
it's called k-12 oh you know the k-12
so this is like uh public schooling
online uh do they have such things like
that on something like a
k-12 that many parents use
oh yes and i will show you i have in
these um slides that i'm showing you
these are for teenagers here but middle
school and high school but
this for instance right here uh the
queer referring this is a coloring sheet
for elementary grades
and this is through black lives matter
curriculum that's being
pushed into our schools through the
teachers union
and one of the coloring sheets says
now remember queer they've changed the
definition of queer it doesn't just mean
gay and lesbian or even bisexual it
means
all-encompassing identities so
and those keep increasing okay it's
open-ended
so it says everybody has the right to
choose who they love
and the kind of family they want by
listening to their own heart and mind
you're going to see this um repeated
over and over listening to their
own heart and mind now i noticed they
have it here in arabic
also yeah why is that i find that
interesting because
um they have this ethnic studies right
now in the state of california
we are um having a community input
process where they're
asking people in the state to give input
before the state board of education
votes on this new curriculum well in the
curriculum that i've read
um again they're they're they are
putting
race and skin color under the umbrella
of lgbtq plus plus plus
so what i did um eddie
is i asked the california department of
ed to please provide
it in other languages such as spanish
and arabic
so that all of our immigrant parents can
participate in the community input
process
including asian languages and they said
we're sorry but we only have it in
english
so basically here they are trying to say
they celebrate diversity
when they excluded and discriminated
anybody who didn't speak english from
the process
and i find that very hypocritical it
interesting it's just unbelievable to me
so but what i find interesting is i said
okay
so you won't tell parents in their
mother tongue or immigrant parents
but yet you'll tell their children in
their mother tongue
you have it in arabic and in spanish
for children but you don't have it for
the parents
don't you find that interesting it's
deceptive it's insidious
and it's a betrayal of parent trust
i couldn't find better words to describe
that well you uh very brave for calling
this out
like well they know that kids are
moldable and impressionable
but they know that parents will buck
against this so they're going behind the
parents backs
teaching children things that they know
their parents won't agree with
and then they're having teaching kids
how to advocate
for these things um and past laws that
go
that remove parent rights wow okay so
here's another coloring sheet again this
is for elementary grades through the
black lives matter curriculum
and it says here now now now before you
go you mentioned coloring sheets
so this is i mean kids that color
are usually around the age of what this
is elementary grades this is second
third fourth grade so so we're talking
about what eight what number are we at
five six seven like four five
seven eight nine yeah
wow these very young minds that are just
now
uh at their ripe age and they're
coloring the stuff in
yeah and they know when they color it i
mean that's a lot of
uh you know it's getting ingrained yeah
it's a lot of intentional focus so this
one here's here it is in arabic
but in english it says everybody has the
right to choose
to choose look at how they're using the
word choose to choose their own gender
by listening to their own heart and mind
everyone gets to choose if they are a
girl
or a boy or both or
neither or something else and no one
else gets to choose
for them so now they're telling them
gender is a choice of many choices
and only your heart and mind can tell
you what that is so
it's not the quran that's going to tell
you it's not your parents
it's not your biological dna it's not
you know um the bible or your religion
it's only whatever your mind is telling
you after we confuse you with these many
choices
through the curriculum the way we look
at it i mean it's quite simple
uh you have creation then you have a
creator the one who created creation is
the one who lays the blueprint he tells
us how and what and
everything we need to know in this life
and doesn't leave this
also for guesswork so uh the one who
created us tells us he chooses for us
so now it's like you become you become
you become the deity of yourself so it's
making you into a like a god
almost like you hit the nail on the head
that is exactly what it is
you are becoming a god as unto yourself
because
if there's one thing that we don't
choose for ourselves
it's our gender it's our it's our sex
you know um you're either
xy or an xx as far as the chromosomes
and they're trying to tell kids that
this
this gender choices is based in science
when that's not the case in fact um in
reading through the
preschool you know they want to have
universal preschool now
and newsom is trying to pass out
governor newsom and i read through the
glossary
for this uh national preschool standards
and it said under gender that gender
according to science was fluid and
expansive and then
with the national sex ed standards
because i'm saying how can they say this
is science
it's not even common sense um to say
these things
but they literally changed the
definition of fact
in the national sex ed standards they
and it's
how they do this is they use the word or
so it's very
tricky but they'll say oh so the new
word for fact means that it
it's empirical data based on research or
it's an opinion or hypothesis based
on most experts um
opinion most experts so they pretty much
get to choose
who those experts are so we have that in
arabic again and then we come down to
this uh this video okay you know um
we showed this video at the last uh
so i wasn't going to show it again i
figured they could go on my website and
watch it under curriculum
what's the website again what's the
website again now that you set up my
website and i it's actually the last
slide on the um google slide
show that i said okay it's um brenda for
kids the number four brenda
for kids we'll have that up okay so now
you come to this term now
that is usually used by
some of the people who've been victims
of the hate machine so they throw this
out
how is this now incorporated this term
radical islam for everybody who knows
who studies islam means to
acquire peace by submitting yourself
entirely to the owner of peace the
creator to heavens and earth to submit
your will to god's will so
this islam cannot be radical uh so why
are they using this
um they're using it just like black
lives matter um they want to incorporate
lgbt with the black lives matter
movement
so that you're you're fighting for
your rights and your identity your
authentic self
so what it says here is facing race
is the largest racial justice conference
in america
this year and this is a conference that
they had in detroit
um this particular student nadim and i
will be presenting our newest workshop
radical islam
lessons of muslim liberation for
from queer muslim youth activists and
we're so excited to share
okay and i think this um emblem really
says it all because a lot of people this
one with the fist
yes because what it's showing is you see
this a lot
um the fist you know meaning we're
activists we're gonna fight
for our rights we're trying to it's it's
what they're doing is starting another
civil rights movement
trying to use it under martin luther
king jr but really
um to me that's just a smoke screen
they're using the
the race and the skin color as a smoke
screen for their true
goal and that's to promote um
these various sexual orientations and
various genders
[Music]
okay here we go um for ethnic studies
you know let's fight for ethnic studies
in our districts and in our education
uh it shows a kid uh yelling through a
microphone education for liberation
it's all coming under the umbrella of
liberty if you could go back to that
slide just for one second
i like what you said i mean you have
good slogans like of justice
peace you know unity so but then what
you're saying is these are just smoke
screens because
you can go ahead and push the beautiful
slogans but what's actually the shot
that's being given
exactly and here this is really key it
says all we want is our stories to be
taught
what they do is they teach kids um
how to create a testimonial um
your story because nobody can argue with
experience
okay and who and they know
that to influence decision makers like
policy makers
senate senators board members that when
kids come in and tell their stories
and the more emotional the better um it
tugs on that empathy side of decision
makers
to where nobody wants to hurt or harm a
child
or make them feel like they're unwanted
or unaccepted
and we don't you know of course we don't
but this is stepping into indoctrination
where
you're confusing kids um as far as their
genders
you're confusing kids and telling them
to experiment discover explore
their sexual orientation and how do you
do that and
um i've been trying to find out how
exactly they're wanting to
have these kids explore because they use
a lot of general terminology
but then when i go to these sites like
healthy tea network
um that is training sex educators
it's actually telling you know you can
go to these websites yourself
and it's endorsing pornography it's
endorsing
ways that they can experiment virtually
um and then it gets them hooked on these
things
you know so that they want to just go
deeper and deeper and deeper into these
things
and it's a black hole i mean it just
takes them into all these rabbit holes
um on the web
wow you said so you're connecting it to
pornography
to just pretty much just following um
a never-ending black hole that you fall
into a black hole of uh
chaos and confusion well absolutely and
you know
every kid wants to feel special i mean
the adolescence is a time where
you're trying to figure out who you are
and a lot of times
you're individuating so you might be
going against status quo as it is you
know and
you never think that your parents you
know your parents don't really know
what's going on
um everybody goes through that you are
becoming your own person
and so what they're doing is exploiting
that
time of life um and they're trying to
open up this pandora's box
for them and they're affirming it
through
many different ways through education
education okay
this next one um okay so that's where i
mentioned k-12 so this is uh now
this is what i'm talking about the k-12
yes poor continent
so if you see um and please go to my
website i've written
articles that will give you a summary um
and i give the page numbers and i give
the document
so you can see the documents for
yourself you don't have to take my word
for it
um this is put out by advocates for
youth
by um sikhis which is sex information
anyways through the united states it is
a private organization but um
anyways it's like i said again this is
using gender and sexual orientation as
above and beyond it is saying it's ever
expansive
ever-changing ever evolving um
and it is equating it with ethnicity and
race
so this is core content skills in the
k-12
curriculum is this where is an elective
course
uh or is this something that you have to
take
so what they do is integrate now in the
state of california
we endorse this document
um not all state education
um department so everybody it's
different depends what states
okay so it depends where you're at
okay okay so this is um polymory
it is non-monogamous relationships
that's now being
endorsed in the state of california
starting in seventh grade
and this was um in our health framework
it's a sexual orientation that they're
saying
you know should be respected and
included in
yeah polymory
okay um i wanted to look at take us so
that that would be this is taught in
seventh grade so this is
school starting in seventh grade they're
teaching this
their t now it might it starts as just
kind of a one-liner and i'm going to
show you
a video actually it would be good if i
showed this video
um now about the sexual orientations
for elementary kids do you have that
link that i sent you
yes okay let's go this is for elementary
school
sexual orientation describes who you are
attracted to
may fall in love with and may have a
sexual relationship with
everyone has a sexual orientation and
there are different words to describe
different sexual orientations many
people are familiar with terms like
heterosexual
gay lesbian and bisexual
but those aren't the only sexual
orientations out there
for example some people identify as
pansexual
which means they are attracted to people
of all genders
many pansexual people feel that gender
has little to do with their attractions
in other words they are attracted to a
person not to that person's gender
some people are asexual sometimes called
ace so you see how they are using
um lots of different sexual orientations
it's way beyond just
gay and lesbian and bisexual um
it covers a lot of different types of
sexualities it's interesting in the
elementary cartoons through omaze.org
um probably use salads a lot in
vegetables because of course you
kids associate salads and vegetables
with healthy
um and i had a friend of mine who's
much more younger than me
um and told me do you know what tossed
salad is
as far as the slang and i said no they
said well why don't you look it up in
the urban dictionary
and i did and i was quite shocked at
what i found
i'm not going to even say what it means
but if you want to know what it means
in younger generations
look it up for yourself under urban
dictionary top solid
and you'll find out why they're using
salads a lot
in their illustrations
wow they actually have it defined there
in the dictionary this uh
what toss salad not in the webster
dictionary but
in the urban dictionary urban dictionary
dictionary is
kind of like what things mean in slang
i don't like street street wise
no i had to kind of get up to speed on
some of those street wise
so now so now in the cartoons they're
actually showing this tossed salad
and now connecting the dot connecting
everything together
yes because what uh tossed salad
it's a term that means [ __ ] and i'm
not going to go into what that means but
it is something a sexual act
that they had in our sex education
curriculum
they included yes yes yes um
so if so the national let's see
where are we here um why don't you go
back to
let's see the trans there you go that
one
so um when i'm talking about genders
like i said it's not just
trans so they're in the national sex
ed standards they actually even changed
the definition of
sexual to mean an umbrella term
encompassing
all non-conforming genders so when you
see the word non-binary
non-binary means you can be both gender
neither gender
something in between uh gender queer
gender fluid
all these different types of genders um
and transgender is actually binary
because binary means either male or
female
non-binary means it's something other
than male or female
okay so it gets really confusing
for parents but under the lgbtq when
they're teaching this
q means queer or questioning
you see that um word questioning under
the little guy with
a question so the way i see this is here
they're giving them
all these different genders and
i think just totally creating confusion
i mean it's confusing to me as an adult
i can only imagine as a child
how confusing this is and then they show
them
this is what they do with these cartoons
first they tell them okay we're going to
prepare you for puberty so
maybe you're in third or fourth grade
and
you're gonna we're preparing you for
what's going to be happening to your
body these changes that are going to
come about
and i i don't have the puberty video up
here but it is on my website
and it kind of scares them like oh of
course puberty is kind of scary your
body's changing you
get pimples you know it's an awkward
stage of life
so what kid isn't gonna think that oh
well i'm not really sure yet what my
gender is and
puberty sounds horrifying so they tell
kids well if you're not sure
what your gender is don't worry you can
go on puberty blockers to
give yourself more time to decide so it
stops puberty it stalls
it so that you can have more time to
decide
we touched upon that last time and this
is actually beyond deception this is a
lie
because anytime you interfere with the
natural process here
it's not just like you can just turn off
a switch and then just turn it back on i
mean
the creation is the process being made
in a certain way and and
not just from the uh interrupting you
know from
the physical physical biological sense
all these things you have so many
it's a health disaster just waiting to
happen when you're just interfering in
the natural process
yeah in that book um that it's on my
website under resources called
irreparable damage
and um abigail schreyer she did a
fantastic job she works
um with wall uh oh i forget which one
anyways she's a journalist and a lawyer
but she has quotes from a lot of
psychologists from
medical professionals many that are
saying no this is not good and many
testimonials from
kids that have gone through this process
that are experiencing
huge regrets who are permanently
sterilized
who have maybe had double mastectomies
um specifically she's focusing on
adolescent and young adult girls
but and in her book she talks about how
once they go on puberty blockers
i didn't know this until i read the book
that 100
of them go towards hormone therapy which
in time and it doesn't take that much
time does sterilize
wow so moving on to this uh where it
says spiritual abuse now i wanted to ask
though if you'd be willing to
show the video on um puberty blockers
the cartoon that they're showing kids
what gender are you a person who is
transgender
is someone whose internal sense of their
gender being a boy
girl or something else doesn't match
their physical body
people who feel this way sometimes feel
anxious when they begin to reach puberty
and their body
starts to change in ways that don't
match their internal sense of their
gender
these feelings are totally normal if you
feel you want more time to explore how
you feel about your gender before your
body starts to change
it's important to talk with a parent
counselor therapist or doctor
about the feelings you have regarding
your gender after some discussion in
counseling you may be referred to an
endocrinologist
endocrinologists specialize in hormones
and they are the most likely to
prescribe
puberty blockers for someone who wants
them puberty blockers are medications
that will stop your body from changing
they are usually given as an injection
or an implant
they block the production of hormones to
stop or delay the physical changes of
puberty
the effects of the medication are only
temporary so if a person stops using
puberty blockers
the physical changes of puberty will
begin again
whether you identify as male female
genderqueer or something else
you're perfectly normal and there are
lots of ways to manage puberty
so that it can be a fun exciting time
rather than a scary or stressful one
okay maybe you need more time to get to
know yourself
this is what they're teaching them to do
to teach them that
for the sake of equity we need to pass
laws
that cover the insurance costs for
puberty blockers
hormone therapy uh double mastectomies
any kind of surgeries that can mutilate
your body
to make you the person that you believe
that you are
so that you can have a happy life so
what in california just about a month
ago our insurance commissioner under
governor newsom
um just passed a policy saying that
double
mastectomies will now be covered
by insurance companies um starting at
age 16
for girls and i i just
gets horrific i
it's unbelievable i i cried when i read
that
i cried because you know i think about
so many young girls who
i was a tomboy myself you know as a
young child i like to play with
drugs and pirates and you know and if i
would have
heard some of these things as a child i
would have definitely thought
i must be a boy you know because of the
things that i like
um but you know when i went through
puberty i i just grew out of it
and my parents didn't make it a big deal
um
i just think kids need to be kids you
know we need to just let them be kids
and grow up
and not confuse them with all of this
it's
it's that's child abuse how do you in
the last uh
10 minutes that we have i want to get
through these slides and ask you a
couple more questions
one one i want to know is uh how do you
i mean this is just so apparently clear
when you look at it you know
someone who is a christian someone who's
muslim somebody who's
a person of god of the creator someone
who wants to live a morally upright life
you know
has that purpose in life direction in
life i mean these things are
you know just even just for a human
being in general someone who just had
uses common sense
right uh so it's just apparently clear
but how does it become so not apparently
clear for others
like that when you're in education
system do you sit and talk with other
teachers and they're just like
you know scratching their head or or are
you because it seems like you're going
against a lot
against a lot equals a lot of people who
are not getting it
well i really think they're keeping
adults and parents in the dark about
this
um they're bringing it in
through a lot of uh virtual means now
teachers a lot of teachers don't agree
with this
and some are unaware of it it just
depends on what school district you're
in as
far as how much it's getting pushed it's
becoming more
progressive and to be honest i mean with
biden
as our president his wife
jill biden is an nea which is a national
educator
association the teachers union
nationally she's a member because she's
a professor a college professor
so i have been on statewide conference
calls with her
and they fully endorse this
i mean not to get super political here
but you know
the reason trump was for school choice
so is betsy devos
they that's why the teachers union hated
them because he wanted to give parents
the choice
of what kind of education they have but
the teachers union does not they want
all kids to be only in public schools
um for the sake of indoctrination
so they they want all kids to be in
schools
and that would exclude and not permit
homeschooling
well school choice such as um
we're gonna go for this in the state of
california i'm working with some
agencies right now
to put school choice on the ballot um
which
would there's about about nine thousand
dollars per student um per year
that's allocated through um tax federal
funding state funding
and those dollars follow the child
into the public schools that's why
attendance is a big deal because that's
where they get their funding
but school choice says that parents get
to take that money
because they're tax and they get to let
that money follow the child to the
school of their choice whether it be
a private school a charter school home
school
they get to let those tax dollars follow
the child to the school they want
i see but the teachers union doesn't
want that they say no public schools
only
and they're staying for the sake of
equity but i don't think it's
equity at all that's where we're talking
about their indoctrinating
that's where the like you said the
indoctrination starts to happen
yeah because the monopolization of power
yeah so moving on here to these uh next
few slides
yeah spiritual abuse um basically what
they're saying uh they passed a
this term in our health framework and
they're trying to say that um
if if your religion
justifies not accepting all these
different genders and sexual
orientations
then you're using religion as a means of
discrimination harassment and
harm if and that includes not using
non-binary pronouns like they
z hear tree and all those pronouns that
i went over last time
okay but i wrote an article well there's
an article
in my um brenda for kids uh website
that talks about how mindfulness uh
so one of the they're using mindfulness
now
as a way of meditation but you see um
mindfulness by them saying this gets you
in touch with your authentic self who
are you
and then you've got all these gender
teachings and sexual orientation
teachings on top of this
do you see how this could become
spiritual abuse in the classroom
because they're opening their kids minds
to
experiment explore after they put in
their minds
all these different doctrines
of genders um and so one of the
um okay this here
is i just wanted to show you you know
it's coming in so many different
directions this um disney movie onward
so if you look at this is this a new
this is coming out
this uh disney came out already through
disney but i don't think parents are
always aware how
how these things are being taught uh
kind of coming in through the back door
so this little character the fairy this
is a non-binary character
because what they did is they took the
extreme
um female and male traits like male
meaning um
it was a kind of like a hells angel uh
motorcycle writer and then you've got
the
pink skin with um the fairy
tutus okay like the ballerina tutu so
you've got
an extreme feminine traits with extreme
masculine traits
being brought together into one
character so you could call this a
non-binary character where this
character is both genders
so stay away from disney well i'm just
saying disney is
definitely using um these things to
bring in and this is mine
this is nothing new with disney i mean
you've seen this is nothing new but
uh i would advise definitely for parents
to i mean just
stay away from disney and what we need
to do as parents is we need to talk to
our kids about these things
and reaffirm them lay that foundation
of what know let's really understand
what gender is
according to a biology and according to
your faith you know um as our creator
absolutely absolutely
um but this is the danger this other one
here it's this is a
go back for a second the lion the lion
so
so we know where's the where where's the
light where's next to the ferry
right there on okay so the lion
uh this character in disney you know
that lions
um male lions have the manes
right well so we've got here this is
actually a transgender character because
you've got a male
lion with the mane but yet it's a woman
character
if you watch the movie so this
shows um an example of transgender but
in the animal form
yeah this is awesome that you're able to
decode this stuff and most people it
just goes over their head they don't get
it it just seems like innocent you know
little cartoons and hey have a good time
sit there
i got some work to do just enjoy
yourself in front of this disney cartoon
but now what's happening is these
messages the indoctrination is happening
uh through these uh cartoons to the kids
it's very scary
as an educator i know that when they
teach teachers how to teach
they say take you how to teach a new
concept to a child
is you have to take something from their
prior learning and make the connection
so what disney is doing is they are
putting into children's
minds these prior learning so that when
these new concepts get taught they'll
say oh now i understand
yeah from that movie onward now it makes
sense
here's another example um from toy story
you see this spork
okay a spork is it's a spoon and a fork
together
and this can be associated with
both genders so you're not just male
you're male and female you're non-binary
just like a spork is a fork and a spoon
together
so that's again taking a prior learning
if you go back again for a second
this here is from frozen and in the
movie let it go
it has the in the bridge it says there's
no right
no wrong no rules for me i'm free
this is very strategic because what
they're doing is they're saying
liberty and freedom has to do with no
morality
it's taking away all boundaries all
boundaries of sexuality all
boundaries of gender all the rules are
gone and that's the true definition of
liberty and freedom
you know it's very dangerous i just
imagine if you took all all the rules
that we live by from day to day i mean
we follow rules to have a civil society
i mean traffic lights stop signs i mean
you have just from basic from small to
big you have rules otherwise if it's
rule
less i mean what do we have so the same
thing the creator sent rules for us to
fire the
to protect us from certain harms and to
put us on a direction that's going to
help to benefit our lives so here it's
just kind of like the uh does that will
culture you know they have this uh
slogan out there by some of these like
jay-z and all these it's called the do
as thy will
aleister crossley have you have you
heard of him um
vaguely alistair crowley
uh this is a lot a lot of some a lot of
these um
uh people um follow his book and his
teachings he has this uh
pretty much this philosophy so this is
just nothing new it's just basically
follow your whims and desires and do
whatever you want
and it doesn't matter if you end up
falling off the bridge while doing that
you know
right whatever your things and pleasures
whatever brings you pleasure and
happiness go for it
yeah so that's what you said earlier i
mean that's just an open door to the
next letter that's going to come into
the alphabet movement is the pedophilia
i yeah because isn't it interesting that
they are leaving it open-ended
they're literally wanting us to give it
to me it's like giving a signed blank
check to the state
and you know because they're just saying
oh we're just going to make this
open-ended
but i said well why aren't you
explicitly stating that
um pedophilia cannot be
in that alphabet but they're not doing
it they're not doing it
there's a reason so this
uh to the right here this is from a car
another cartoon is this an older newer
cartoon
oh this one to the right um that is
actually frozen
it's from the song let it go
yeah last time you uh gave us the
the inside scoop of that toy called it
was pretty popular uh
poopsie i have to look at a lot of these
toys i went into target um
the lol dolls if you look at the um boy
dolls
their names are spice and sugar do you
find that strange
the lol boy dolls are called spice and
sugar
i find that very odd um
so this next one here i want to show you
the next slide
uh this is i i just want to tell parents
to be careful with student surveys
you can opt your kids out of student
surveys because the student surveys are
asking kids about
what gender they are what sexual
orientation they are
and they're very um very invasive
about asking you questions about your
family and you could
from early on just opt them out you can
opt them out of sex education as far as
it gets tricky on that but you know i
would just encourage
imams to come together and i really
believe that we need to come together as
interfaith communities
for the sake of our children and have
alternatives in education
whether it be school choice or learning
pods
um where there's like home school or
increa you know decreasing the price of
our private schools and
increasing our enrollment in our private
schools um
i don't know but we need some creative
solutions i'm
don't know all the answers but we are in
a crisis situation
and our kids are under assault and um
we need some alternatives
now from the last program that we did we
actually invited many of the community
leaders imam sheikhs
to reach out to you and some actually
did how was that experience
and was there a bridge that was built
and some collaboration
that's you guys been working on to make
some of these
ideas a reality well um
we still have a ways to go i am working
with different um
groups and i'm hoping to increase that
as far as
um you know honestly this this whole
thing that's been going on in our
country
that's literally dividing us um
it's strategically dividing us and i
think we need to do just the opposite we
need to instead come together
as different races different language
groups different faiths
for the love of our children and um
unite
where they want to isolate and divide we
need to choose to unite
um and you know see our things that we
have in common which is to protect our
kids
to protect that very sacred parent-child
relationship
protect our families protect religious
freedoms and our values
thank you so much for sharing all this
with us people can go to brenda
for kids brenda for kids and you can
contact me um
by there is a web there's an email you
can contact
me that way um websack for kids and i
encourage you to do so
i i still do have facebook though i'm
not sure with the censorship how long
that's going to be
going on with it there's been a lot of
censorship so um
some of the things i've put up have been
taken down um but
i'll still use it as much as i can to
reach out to people and
connect through messaging god bless you
thank you so much
and if you like this episode of today's
show like this video
share this video far and wide and
support us on our patreon page so we can
continue this work
thank you for tuning in peace be with
you assalamu alaikum
subscribe right now